on vient d'apprendre donc c'est
confirmations les trois dirigeants
viendront à Paris on n'a pas plus de
précision bien sûr voilà on a pas encore
toutes les modalités de ce dispositif ce
qui est sûr donc c'est que ce soir à
l'Élysée il y aura un dîner autour
d'Emmanuel Macron dîner auquel
participera évidemment volody mirzelens
qui arrivera de Londres et le chancelier
Olaf Scholtz qui arrivera de Berlin donc
déjà sur le symbole c'est important ça
veut dire que entre Londres et Bruxelles
où il doit se rendre demain en fin de
matinée et bien il fait quand même une
halte à Paris avec le chancelier
allemand bref il s'arrête voir le couple
franco-allemand qui joue un rôle
évidemment central au sein de l'Union
européenne européenne mais qui a été
aussi critiquée pour ces positionnements
qui
ont été parfois jugés un peu hésitants
réticent le fait par exemple qu'Emmanuel
Macron maintienne ses conversations
téléphoniques à Vladimir machines ou
qu'ils disent que dans le cadre d'un
règlement futur de la paix en Europe il
fallait que la Russie elle aussi est des
garanties de sécurité tout cela est très
mal passé en Ukraine mais par ailleurs
il y a le volet militaire la livraison
des canons César et puis voilà qui il
est en mission aussi visiblement en
Europe sur les avions de chasse là
maintenant son agenda c'est les avions
de chasse il en a parlé à Londres il va
certainement en parler ce soir à Paris
pour le moment